non cancérogènes c'est ce que conclut la
gg le groupe de pays chargés de la
réévaluation du glyphosate la gg a remis
son premier rapport aux autorités
européennes le 15 juin dernier les
quatre états non identifié aucune
propriétés cancérogènes ray pro toxiques
ou encore mutagènes qui pourrait
justifier l'interdiction du glyphosate
là j'ai conclu que le glyphosate
répondent aux critères d'approbation
pour la santé humaine tel que défini
dans le règlement cee numéro 1107 2009
et ses amendements pour l'approbation en
tant que substance active a utilisé dans
les produits phytopharmaceutiques des
conclusions synonyme de scandale pour
les ong générations futures d'autant
qu'elle le rappel l'herbicide est classé
cancérigène probable et cela depuis 2015
par le centre international de recherche
sur le cancer
le cnrc rattaché à l'om s il est
vraiment décevant de voir aujourd'hui le
groupe de pays en charge de la
réévaluation du glyphosate dont la
france
reprendre la même litanie de l'innocuité
du glyphosate
alors que le poids des preuves
scientifiques est accablant pour cette
molécule comme l'ont rappelé les
scientifiques du cnrc en 2015
mais nous sommes au tout début du
processus et générations futures ainsi
que toutes les ong du réseau pesticide
action network europe vont maintenant
épluché ce rapport et le critiquer en
détail à la lumière des données
scientifiques disponibles montrant les
effets cancérogènes et génotoxique du
glyphosate
il est plus que temps de se débarrasser
de cet herbicide dangereux en europe et
en france
même son de cloche du côté de l'alliance
pour la santé et l'environnement
pour cette organisation qui regroupe de
nombreuses associations
cette décision pose clairement la
question de l'indépendance des
évaluations faites sur les produits
comme le glyphosate l'annoncent
d'aujourd'hui sur la sécurité du
glyphosate est un grand pas en arrière
et met en lumière les questions qui
subsistent quant à l'objectivité et à
l'indépendance de l'évaluation de la
sécurité des pesticides par l'europe
pour rappel le glyphosate l herbicide le
plus utilisé dans le monde
a été une nouvelle fois autorisée au
sein de l'union européenne en 2017 pour
une durée de cinq ans jusqu'en 2022 donc
après examen du rapport l'autorité
européenne de sécurité des aliments et
l'agencé européenne des produits
chimiques vont organiser des
consultations ouvertes au public en
septembre les deux entités s'exprimeront
ensuite sur les domaines qui les
concernent
puis enfin reviendra à la commission
européenne de statuer sur le
renouvellement ou non de l'autorisation
du glyphosate